amira mohammed ali aus der linksfraktion
dort vorsitzende ist die nächste
rednerin sehr geehrt präsident kollegen
den kollegen sehr geehrte frau
bundeskanzlerin ja seit über einem jahr
leben wir in der pandemie und schon viel
zu lange herrschen chaos und leere
versprechungen in kabinett und kanzler
ausbauen müssen das millionenfach die
menschen in diesem land auch jetzt
wieder direkt vor den osterferien frau
bundeskanzlerin ich muss es leider so
klar sagen wenn ihre bundesregierung bei
der impfstoff beschaffung der strategie
nicht so kläglich versagt hätte dann
hätte diese dritte welle entscheidend
abgemildert wenn nicht sogar vermieden
werden können und an diesem tag eine
euro kritiker bei der osternacht nehmen
wir die schnelltest im september letzten
jahres sagte gesundheitsminister sparen
ich zitiere ich möchte dass wir für
bestimmte situationen zum beispiel für
den besuch im pflegeheim den schnelltest
deutlich häufiger damit meine ich
millionenfach einsetzen was ist daraus
geworden
heute monate später gibt es immer noch
nicht genügend test wo sie gebraucht
während allen voran an den schulen
der präsident des deutschen
lehrerverbandes sagt neun von zehn
spielen sind meilenweit von einer
ausreichenden ausstattung mit tests
entfernt die aber nötig wären um
sicheren präsenzunterricht zu
gewährleisten
die lehrergewerkschaft bildung und
erziehung attestiert ihnen deshalb total
versagen zu recht ihr corona management
ist inzwischen man kann es nicht anders
sagen ein trümmerhaufen und das nicht
nur weil die maßnahmenpakete immer
verwirrender und chaotischer werden
sondern weil effektiven und von
renommierten wissenschaftlern angelegte
maßnahmen einfach nicht getroffen werden
zum beispiel die verpflichtung zum home
office überall da wo das möglich ist
noch immer
müssen viele menschen in großraumbüros
setzen weil die arbeitgeber dass rom
auch das einfach nicht erlauben
sie werden gezwungen sich einem
unnötigen infektionsrisiko auszusetzen
und das risiko ist ganz erheblich
die tu berlin hat in einer studie
ermittelt dass wir eine eine mit corona
mpc person in einem großraumbüro im
schnitt acht weitere menschen ansteckt
und dass man das büro nur zur hälfte
besetzt es diesen trend im treiber den
muss man doch abstellen aber wieder
heimat schmecken sie vor der arbeitgeber
lobby 1 ist unsere antwort eine der
größten krisen die unser land erlebt hat
gleich das regierungshandeln mehr und
mehr einer preiser team und das nicht
nur weil sie allen ernstes die versager
andreas scheuer und jens spahn
die task force für die korona fest
leiten lassen jetzt müssen sie außerdem
zum xten mal die korona hilfen für
unternehmen nachjustieren
im beschluss dieser woche steht dazu
dass sie für die besonders schwer
betroffen oder neben zitat ein
ergänzendes hilfsinstrument im rahmen
europarechtlichen vorgaben entwickeln
wollen wie muss das klingen in den ohren
als der unternehmer unternehmer der solo
selbstständigen der künstlerinnen und
künstler die meterlange formulare für
den november und dezember hilfen
ausgefüllt haben und bis heute auf deren
auszahlung warten
wie oft wollen sie den den das wasser
bis zum hals steht den rettungsring
eigentlich noch ankündigen werfen sie
ihn endlich frau bundeskanzlerin
sie haben es nicht geschafft dass wir
alle endlich licht am ende des tunnels
sehen sie haben es nicht geschafft
hoffnungen perspektive zu geben und das
ergebnis ist dass bei immer mehr
menschen das vertrauen in politik
verloren geht und das gilt nicht nur für
deutschland ist gilt auch für die
europäische union
und um es noch mal klar zu sagen
natürlich war es richtig auf eine
gemeinsame lösung bei der impfstoff
beschaffung zu setzen aber das ergebnis
war nun mal katastrophal
dabei hatte ich entspannen im oktober
noch großspurig erklärt zitat wir
sichern uns deutlich mehr impfstoff als
wir brauchen werden und er sagte sogar
etwas übrig bliebe könnte man es anderen
ländern weiter verkaufen oder armen
nationen spenden ein guter plan aber
leider ist es wieder nur bei den
ankündigungen geblieben
bis heute haben gerade einmal acht
prozent der menschen in der eu
die zweifach impfung bekommen das doch
ein armutszeugnis und nicht dass wir
damit meilenweit entfernt sind von der
retten denn jeden immunität
es bedeutet auch dass nach inzwischen
drei monaten seit dem start ist immer
noch nicht gelungen ist die
verwundbarsten menschen unserer
gesellschaft zu schützen
meiner mutter zum beispiel geht es wie
vielen älteren menschen sie ist 78 jahre
alt hat sogar multiple vorerkrankungen
aber bis heute keinen impftermin in
aussicht und damit ist sie kein
einzelfall sondern der regelfall und das
geht doch so nicht denn es betrifft
nicht nur die betroffenen menschen ist
betrifft vielmehr menschen denn ich bin
mir sicher das ist viel so geht wie mir
nämlich dass ihnen ein riesiger stein
vom herzen fallen würde wenn sie wüssten
dass die eltern die großeltern das
andere geliebte menschen bei denen ein
schwerer krankheitsverlauf zu erwarten
ist endlich geschützt während das wäre
so wichtig es muss alles daran gesetzt
werden dass mehr impfstoff produziert
wird die produktionskapazitäten müssen
ausgebaut werden ohne wenn und aber
und ja auch die patientin müssen
freigegeben werden kolleginnen
wer immer als ich das hier gefordert
aber da gab es herbe kritik von seiten
der union
es hieß man würde damit angeblich
innovationsstandort deutschland
zerstören
das war damals der kollege nüßlein der
ist ja jetzt nicht mehr bei der union
dabei vielleicht sind sie jetzt sehr
offen für diese idee aus brüssel kommen
derweil wieder falsche signale so
behauptete der binnenmarktkommissar
thierry breton gerade erst steif und
fest ist gebe absolut keinen bedarf am
russischen impfstoff gleichzeitig
diskutiert man wegen der impfstoff knapp
hat einen exportstopp für impfstoffe aus
der eu das passt doch nicht zusammen
natürlich muss der russische impfstoff
wie jeder andere eingehend geprüft
werden bevor die zulassung erhält und
das muss zügig geschehen der cebit orde
ist übrigens auch zuständig für die
ressorts verteidigung und raumfahrt man
möglicherweise hat der name sportback
fahrer einen schock ausgelöst
nein hier darf es keine ideologischen
scheuklappen geben
meine damen und herren wie falsch die
richtung ist in die diese
bundesregierung unser land steuert das
zeigt eine zahlen während der korona
krise in die zahl der pflegekräfte in
deutschland um 9.000 zurück eine
ehemalige krankenpflegerin sagte dazu
gestern im zdf zitat das klatschen die
plätzchen und ein pandemie bonus die
nicht mal alle bekommen haben
dieser umgang mit uns hat mir den
letzten glauben an eine bessere
perspektive in meine damen und herren
so kann es doch nicht weitergehen wir
brauchen einen grundlegenden
politikwechsel aber nicht irgendwann
wir brauchen einen sozialen aufbruch
eine politik die sich konsequent am
gemeinwohl ausrichtet und nicht am
profit der mächtigsten lobbyisten
[Applaus]